test.
Okay, we're good.
Cool. We got some stuff to do today.
Believe we have a nice PR here.
Let's go check
I don't think the New kernels are in
here. Do we? Oh, no. It looks like we
do.
this looks good.
This looks very good.
Plus a lot of code.
I don't generally like um
plus 1300.
Well, let's just go take a look at the
kernels first.
I want to see what the kernels look
like.
Roll out. Copy.
are all profiles.
Okay. So the advantage function here
I've seen this one before though I know
roughly what this entails.
This also has the B float stuff.
We can probably
clean this, but I'm kind of fine with
this being like uh like this for now.
Okay. Compute pri. I do not like these
all being separate kernels like this.
we're still using at multinnomial here
for some reason.
We've got
four launches at least.
I mean this is really not matching the
um
it really is not matching at all the way
we are doing our kernels.
Yeah, I really really do not like the uh
the structure of the refactor here.
Hey user. Hey Pepe.
So we want the kernels, but I do not
like some of the structural stuff in
this.
trying to see if um
this was deleted.
Yeah, I can't write this as is
Yeah, I mean this basically screws up a
whole bunch of the way we have our code
right now. Hey, Liberty, I'm checking
Jonas VR. He's gotten some really nice
speed improvements, but I don't like
some of the refactoring he's done.
Yeah, I also I just particularly do not
like um
splitting stuff up into a million tiny
files is always just a no for me.
Hey Jonah, there you are. Perfect.
So, I'm looking through this. Um the
kernels look reasonable.
I don't like some of the refactoring
here for sure.
So like
the million little files is one thing,
but then there's also
pretty much now the new kernels. This is
taking the kernels out of our big
kernels file that doesn't depend on
torch. And we didn't even have launch
functions before and now they're
separate launch functions.
Um,
and now they're in their own files that
do depend on torch as well.
So this actually demodularizes in a
sense because now
uh now we basically in order to get this
to be
uh in order to use this without torch,
we'd have to either refactor it back or
split everything into like yet another
set of files.
So that I'm not a fan of. I do want to
get the uh the select and copy kernels,
the pryo kernel and the
advantage kernel improvements in though
if we can.
That would be super nice.
Like honestly, this advantage colonel,
there's no reason this advantage colonel
just go can't just go live with our
other colonels now, right?
messaging on Discord. Let me Okay, we'll
get your Discord good for like half an
hour. Cool.
That should be enough time
and then I can spend a bit of time
integrating
profiling remove. Yeah, I mean I can go
integrate the initial kernels now or you
can do uh or you can do the big PR if
you want. So I the main thing is I first
of all I really don't like splitting
stuff into a bunch of files. Uh it makes
it really easy to do this without
realizing it. So this is actually now a
plus300 line commit.
And I actually have no idea how much of
this is now uh like bloat from having
split stuff up because usually when you
split stuff up there's a little bit more
boilerplate bloat and like how much of
this is from the actual kernels, right?
It actually it just makes things very
opaque.
And then the specific restructuring here
like let's see if you did it here as
well.
No, these are the profile ones. So let
me see the actual kernel files
So, wait. Now I'm very confused because
you didn't move all of our other kernels
around, did you?
No. So, you didn't go move all of our
kernels. So, that was good. You split up
the profiling. I'm not a fan of
splitting the profiling, but then look
for all the new kernels, instead of just
adding them into kernels.cu with the
bindings and modules, they're now
separate files. and they no longer have
the property of our current ones where
you can just call this independently
from whatever you want because now this
is tied to torch. Right now I do see
here though that you do have one torch
dependency anyways.
Um
so the way that I would get around this
for now is
well I would give these reasonable names
for whatever the op that this thing is
doing and then you can just put this in
the modules file. So we don't have an
end to end compute pryo kernel yet.
That's fine. But we have at least we'll
have like the module defaf.
Yeah, that's how I would go about it.
And then let me see what you are trying
to do before I dismiss it. Like let me
see what you are trying to do at least
with the profile here.
Yeah. See, this to me this looks like
splitting it up just for the sake of
splitting it up.
Like this doesn't actually I don't think
this accomplishes anything by splitting
it up. Like look, if you were going to
tell me that you split profiles.cu, you
if you were going to tell me that you
split it into two files and one of them
was for torch and one of them was for
not torch then maybe I would consider it
because it gets rid of this gross macro
and crap. Um but I don't think this
accomplishes anything by splitting it up
other than just giving us a ton of tiny
files.
Keep the compute pile. It has
yeah what you can do for compute cryo
it's very simple right you just take um
so uh select and copy just goes in
kernels compute pryo you can just take
part one two and three none of these
depend on torch these can just go into
kernels and then this compute fryocuda
this can just go into modules because
torch modules is a CUDA file so you can
directly call launches like this without
needing any extra wrappers
and it should be pretty simple
And then that also minimizes header
surface because the only thing that has
to get exposed via header is this one
function here.
I think this the next question I have is
one that would just take me um
is probably just I need to do more
kernel dev myself. But does it make more
sense to do like separate launches like
this than it does to
uh just have synchronization within
kernels?
Well, you do have syncs in here.
So wait, why does it need both
synchronizations and separate launches?
I would think it would be one or the
other. No.
is this not just like a reduction at the
end? No, this is quite substantial.
to sum over the entire dimension in part
two.
Okay. Okay. Well, this is me just
needing to do more kernel dev because
most of the kernels I've messed with are
just pretty simple element wise or SQ
wise parallel.
I suppose I don't understand yet when
the optimal time is to have uh separate
launches versus to just do
synchronizations within the kernel.
right? This is just in float. So this is
fine. This can just be in float.
Anything else I should look at while I
have you here, Jonah?
Nope. Okay,
cool.
So, that'll be very nice. Once we have
that merged in, we should get plus about
a million SPS.
I'm a little concerned with some of the
kernel complexity we're adding in here.
Um, unfortunately I don't quite have the
kernel dev experience yet to be able to
like I can't tell if this is minimally
complex or like this is minimal
complexity for this hop yet.
I would also hope that the profiling
you're doing if you're doing it with
cudigraphs on I would hope well I guess
this wasn't cudigraph to begin with so
this will be a true speed enhancement
either way you know
either way I think we're going to want
to do this eventually because we are
going to want to try to move more stuff
to just be in native CUDA
and I think that having like a clean
kernels file is going to be the most
important thing longer term
would be good.
Okay. Um things for us to do,
right? So I believe we had in dev and I
didn't push it yet. We had a whole bunch
of
uh timing and profiling data
on puffer. Let's go check on our latest
sweep just to see if there's anything I
should do here before we kill. This
doesn't look like there's anything
particularly
Yeah. Yeah, this one is kind of good,
right?
Yeah, this is a very clean run. So,
we'll go grab these parameters real
quick
just as our new starting point. I
believe this should be more stable and
then we will get back to cleaning some
stuff up.
right? So, the clip coefficient being
super low is not ideal.
Um,
this should be a better run.
Flip C is at min.
Very weird.
At least they should be more stable.
learning rate is lower.
The model's bigger
grad normally
we need to get the constellation stuff
working so I can just copy um all the
params in one shot.
I don't think we're going to do that
today though.
Where's the VF co? It's 0.1, right?
Not the healthiest.
Total agents 16k.
Mini batch size very big.
two points. Yeah, that's a pretty odd
set of um parameters
worst bug. uh he managed to break Python
itself by he screwed up uh Python C API
memory management. So essentially you
could get a very rare use after free in
the Python internals itself at some
undetermined point hours after the bug
actually was introduced.
And the result was just like all of our
training runs randomly would die 12
hours in with an internal Python error
for a while until we figured that out.
How are you going to figure out that
bug? Well, we didn't initially. It took
me a 12-hour workday, and that was after
it had already like screwed up a bunch
of our dev experiments for a couple
weeks, as well as some of our client
work.
So, I make sure that the uh lesson was
at least learned.
That is a 15 million parameter policy.
That was very chunky.
We run a 15 million parameter policy at
500 KSPS.
Yeah. Okay. The puffer is fast, by the
way. And actually, I think that's even
unfair because that's at a high replay
ratio. So that could be closer to 10.
We can't Yeah, we can't do that at the
same time. Okay.
We had gotten the stats into the
dashboard
like kind of okay, kind of messy. If I
recall
Right. And I was going to figure out um
CPU, GPU, DRAM, VRAM. Right.
that utilization wrapper is probably
crap.
Now, Joseph, I am working on a set of
custom environments. Can you create
multiple MS in the same folder or should
I differentiate them with a flag during
initialization?
Um,
so it will look in like it will look in
the folder by name for your environment.
If you have multiple environments that
are basically different configurations
of the same environment,
uh
you can just like expose config
parameters for those
and keep it one environment. If you have
completely different environments, then
they should be separate folders, one
each.
And we are making this less of a pain in
the ass in Puffer 4. So I believe in
puffer 4 you're not going to need uh
you're not going to need like per
environment Python binds which is going
to be nice. So that's minus one file.
I think we just need DRAM and B RAM.
Honestly,
currently working with 30. Yeah, then
keep it like that. The update to 40 will
be very smooth when you go to do it.
It's pretty minimal.
So, we'll just keep this one in rich.
That's fine. The prints will just stay
Python.
Okay.
Utilization just gets it right here.
This is fine.
And this gets rid of utilization.
What the hell is this app?
Yeah, I when they say they use cloud
code to build this app, I can tell
it's not a good thing.
Okay, so we've got some format crap, but
then this utilization will go away. So,
that'll be nice. Get rid of that.
Possibly can merge a bunch of logs. We
shall see about that.
Um, and then the only jank that will be
left here really will be some of the
sweep stuff, I believe.
Yeah, because we have a whole bunch of
sweep stuff. So, once we clean up logs,
that'll be it.
It's pretty much just how we kick off um
multi sweeps and stuff.
And presumably
I don't know if we can make some of that
go into the sweeps file or not. I don't
think so.
In the meantime, how's our experiment
going?
Okay. So, this is matching for now.
We'll see how long it takes to train.
Uh, this is not a super fast run. I
think that's like an hour.
So, it's just going to just there.
That's fine.
term is really laggy today. It's
annoying.
I'd do something about it, but I'm only
uh streaming for a little bit here.
And then let's see if this still gives
us stats.
Bosses some stats.
That's good.
So sleepy.
I mean, we probably just cluttered the
um the C++ with some crap, but the nice
I think now we we literally only have
one thing left to figure out that's
complicated with the Python, which is
going to be the uh the sweep
integration.
And uh the stat shouldn't be that
complicated to refactor
from the C++.
So I suppose uh then the question is
do we want these log functions to be
separate or is it fine to just have them
together.
We don't really have to decide that at
the moment to be fair.
boss logging
sweeps clean up and four sweeps clean
up.
It's actually very very close now to
what we want where we want it to be.
All right, we have these CC tags that
never got applied.
Let's also have this not be formatted at
all.
Oops.
It's fine.
Torch 2D type.
Just do auto
you type.
Okay, this is fine.
So, it's going to be torch
type
I think it's fine to leave the tensors
like this.
No, this is precision DT type. This is
not um the OBS DT type. We'll
dict methods and end binding agents of
endbinding C.
Doesn't this leak memory?
Right. I remember we We fixed this
already.
Removed state zeroing and reward
clamping.
That's definitely an important thing to
check.
I don't think we've fully went through
the train function yet. Now, this is
going to get a couple kernels added.
It's going to look a little bit
different.
And I think we're going to go do the
same thing that we did on the net call
back. So let me go look at that.
and forward.
Okay.
Well, that's kind of weird.
Not that weird, though. Right.
This is the same code. So, all we're
going to do,
it's a little bit harder here, isn't it?
Because of these graphs.
Yeah. So, it's just a bunch of CUDA
stuff and then the delete stuff at the
bottom.
Okay. 830 lines.
Quite a bit better, I'd say.
couple very minor things I'm giving this
to do
yeah look so if we're ignoring this
massive assreate function and destroy
function
we're only at 500 lines before Yes.
Really? We're going to like not match
here? Seriously?
Most of the complexity in here comes
from cudigraphs honestly which is really
just kind of an intermediate step.
Most likely just an intermediate step.
It depends how much fuse stuff you have.
Cool.
This is very good.
Let me see if we missed any of the um
the pars here
cuz something seems off to me,
Ve unbuffered on thread 16k agents.
I think I applied n
Huh?
That's annoying. That doesn't repro.
Yeah, that just does not repro
correctly.
That's very annoying.
I mean, we're getting all these like
sketchy params though, right? Like 0.1
VF clip. really
Hey, Jess.
Haven't been live for long today. Just
um quick stream. I'm heading off to do
some more client work. I did some in the
morning. I got another client's worth of
work to do in the afternoon today. Uh
but we are doing a little bit of basic
refactoring on the new update.
Jonah stopped by. He's got some custom
kernels, but I didn't like some of the
refactors he did. So, he's going to like
go clean it up again.
Have you had a chance to look through
it? Is isn't it the same course that I
took in my undergrad? I mean, Philip's
my adviser or he was my adviser when I
was a PhD student, right?
So I think I took either that course or
like the you know previous revision of
that course
um first year of my PhD.
I mean the thing is by the time you get
to be a PhD student you kind of already
know all the stuff in those courses or
you better well like you should. So,
I'm going to call this reasonably
cleaned up.
Um, if this is dead, then we there's no
point in us
Yeah, there's no point in us like just
waiting for this thing if this is not
Yeah. So, this is like nowhere near the
original, right? So, we have no idea
why.
Um, no idea why, but this is not good.
Anyways, we can just kill this.
We can get our machine back.
Yeah, breakout's still nice and speedy.
3 second solve.
I think we can commit this. Yeah.
post Philip as an advisor.
I mean, Philip is chill, right? We
pretty much agreed that I was going to
work on like my crazy neural mamimosa,
which was even nuttier back then than it
is now, right? Um, for the whole time.
And
I sort of had my direction on a lot of
stuff.
So, like I didn't really need to be
pointed in a specific direction, right?
There's a lot of stuff on navigating
academia and stuff I learned from him
for sure.
Okay, it's a net negative on net delete
command.
So we are always happy with those.
Oh.
Uh, we can just do
I think this pragma doesn't do anything
anyways.
We can just do this.
still some stuff to clean up, but very
very close, I would say. Now
I can 100% get
to port this.
This is actually very simple.
The thing is, if I actually if I do this
now, I'm going to mess up. Hang on.
Let's not do this. This is going to end
up taking more time than it saves
because it's going to mess Jonah up
because he's still messing with this.
So, let's let Jonah mess with this.
Let's see if
Oh, hang on. I got some messages to read
from Peru.
I'm trying to figure out remaining stuff
here. We did a quick look at sweeps.
Okay. And then there's this parrito
sweep.
When are we getting multiGPU train? It's
already implemented, Jess.
I already did that.
that's um supported in 30 and I added 40
I think last week.
I have not tested it on multiple cards
yet, but I did test it like uh emulating
multiple cards on one card and it seemed
fine.
I don't know. Should be faster than
torches.
Yo, you ready? Hey, Spencer. Cool. Uh,
let me grab uh let me grab some toast
real quick. Spencer, give me a few
minutes and then Yes. Uh, so for
everyone here, thank you for tuning in.
I got some client work to go handle.
If you'd like to support my stuff for
absolutely free, feed this puffer star
on GitHub. Really helps us out. Uh, you
can join the Discord to get involved
with dev. There are a lot of useful
people on here that'll help you out and
you can follow me on X for more RL
content. I will be back probably a
little bit tomorrow morning depending
afternoon if not most likely. And uh
well,